[Musique]
je m'appelle racing comme si le pain
j'ai 27 ans et j'habite à la saline
bah là on est au temple à la
saline-les-hauts donc avec l'association
et doux
[Musique]
nous on est là depuis le matin pour être
réparé façon tout se déroule bien tout
soit prêt à l'heure hautement michaels
et ja rule azzati aux arrêts nous
parlons de la baisse il n'aime ahmed
fall a déjà envahi la salle audubon
depuis lundi ces pistes l'heure mais
après ce type qui rêve et qui rêve déjà
aux connaît cette tradition après lyon
réside à la tête aussi l'inde un retour
quand même pas trop après c'est une
question a été tué et un petit peu comme
ça aussi la cuisine oui c'est quelque
chose de sérieux parce que c'est des
responsabilités qu'on comprend aussi
c'est parce que c'est quand même faire
de la nourriture à pois pois des gens
que ce soit pour les divinités
donc il faut que ça soit bon
[Musique]
c'est bon bon caractère il aimerait bien
aider pas à sylvain même l'a déjà fait à
tous à toutes les sauces ils passent pas
à sylvain très intelligent et en
quatrième génération à cuisiner de ma
famille je me suis dit bon il est temps
il est temps de mettre ça sur papier
[Musique]
ça c'est pour le moment ma besoin de ça
aussi pour changer un peu les idées pour
trouver un petit peu personnellement
aussi
[Musique]
c'est le récif
là où j'ai travaillé je pourrais 2010
mai 2010 et de métier j'ai été plongé
ainsi pour une cuisine apprentis cuisine
en crp
et apprentis cuisiniers en bp là on est
dans la cuisine est juste ici le bureau
du chef
bonjour chef et bien première chose à
faire ou dire bonjour
sinon ça passe pas couleurs secondaires
la cuisine
si la plonge voilà c'est ici que j'ai
commencé un patch en tant que chef j'ai
l'oeil pour voir un peu les gens qui
sortent du lot et j'ai repéré sylvain et
je me suis un peu intéressé à son
parcours et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il n'avait pas le diplôme
donc j'ai insisté auprès de sylvain pour
qu'il fasse une formation mois elle
suffire mais par rapport aux où il est
passé parce qu'il voulait pas l'appétit
et quand il met en avant les matches et
essaye d'avoir rien je sais pas bien
c'est venu comme ça naturellement et il
ya eu comme comme un lien avec la
cuisine ou où c'était pas moi qui
faisais appel le travail mais le travail
qu'il faisait appel à moi en fait
[Musique]
ça c'est un travail d'équipé
voilà tout le monde participe chacun met
son grain de sel dans cette curiosité
qui fait justement le vrai professionnel
il se renseigne il pose les questions
c'est en écoutant en regardant c'est
comme ça que j'ai reçus en fait
[Musique]
rincez vos sols enlevé et kate sont
collés dessus seychelles est la moitié à
marine et l'autre moitié sur un bac
c'est bon on y voit une appréhension
quand on
on revient ici avec le prix d'excellence
bas
j'ai gagné le présenter de partir encore
une fois en métropole mon père il m'a
dit écoute
le premier train ils passent faut pas
attendre le deuxième pour prendre le
premier train sur situe par ailleurs
métropole dans un grand établissement
comme dit sa voix que tu avais été en
sage tu sais pertinemment que ce sont
des établissements qui demande beaucoup
de rigueur
tu vas faire beaucoup d'heures et tu vas
surtout gagnant mérite et tu vas surtout
gagnant savoir je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il a de bonnes bases pour être un très
bon cuisinier
après il a quatre années de scolarité il
faut qu'il a filmé tout ça il va falloir
qu'il travaille maintenant pour pouvoir
acquérir de l'expérience au tout mais là
un bon un très très bon je pense que là
bas je vois autre chose vers poignée
d'autres choses mais oubliez ce que j'ai
appris ici ce que j'ai vécu ici je ne
sais pas peut pas oublier
je souhaite bonne chance et bonne
réussite et les plus loin parce que
l'entité le cargo et ça va et pour celle
là c'est une terre sylvain silva chi il
continue
ces études qui les pousse un peu une qui
fait des mentions complémentaires
sylvain peut très bien devenir un
directeur d'hôtel
moi ça fait comme un livre qui sont
ouverts et bien moi je fais tout pour
garder ce livret a est
ce que j'écris un beau chapitre
[Musique]